JAIR DARKE: Oh my god.
Another one, another one.
Wait.
[bleep]
JASON DARKE: He's got
a dolphin in his mouth.
NARRATOR: Sharks and dolphins.
This vicious rivalry has been
raging for millions of years.
Two Australian oystermen
get a firsthand look
at the aftermath of a battle.
Oh my god.
Another one, another one.
Oy.
Oy, massive one.
Massive one.
[bleep] Look at it.
That just come out from
underneath the boat.
The moment I saw
the second shark,
adrenaline started
pumping through my veins.
I didn't know what
just happened.
That scared the
[bleep] out of me.
Second shark was
bigger than the first.
It would have been 12
to 14 foot, probably,
but it was definitely bigger.
It was huge.
JAIR DARKE: Oy,
they're fighting.
They're fighting.
[bleep] He just
stole that dolphin.
[inaudible] He just
stole the dolphin.
[interposing voices]
JASON DARKE: Look at
the size of the thing.
NARRATOR: A dolphin is
worth fighting over.
We do know that
if a shark gets
the opportunity to eat a
dolphin, they absolutely will.
In fact, it's a really
prized food source.
Like many marine mammals,
dolphins have all this blubber.
So that's a good
nutritious meal.
NARRATOR: From
the injuries, it's
clear the dolphin was initially
attacked from behind and below.
He swam straight past us
with the dolphin in his mouth.
NARRATOR: How did the shark get
past this dolphin's defenses?
Dolphins are
really quite zippy.
They can outmaneuver
a shark fairly
easily, especially if they're
in deeper or open water spaces.
NARRATOR: To understand
how sharks catch
these slippery
creatures, the team
heads to a beach that
offers a unique look
at Shark Bay's dolphins.
So we're right now at
Monkey Mia in Shark Bay.
There has been 20 years
of really incredible
ecological and
biological research
on the interactions between
sharks and dolphins.
NARRATOR: Dolphins
were first drawn
here in the 1960s by
fishermen sharing their catch.
Today, this site is regulated by
the Parks and Wildlife Service.
We have some friendly dolphins
that come here very regularly.
And we get to see them
up close and personal,
which is really special.
NARRATOR: No need for a
baited underwater camera.
Here, dolphins come to you.
And they're covered in scars.
So this individual that's
just approaching us just now
is called Piccolo.
And you can see on her
dorsal and on her back,
she's got scars from
encounters with sharks.
Dolphins make this trade off.
A lot of the food that they
want most and the easy fishing
grounds, the yummy fish occur
around shallow seagrass beds.
Unfortunately, that's
also where tiger sharks
preferentially like to hunt.
NARRATOR: To protect themselves,
dolphins have a secret weapon--
echolocation.
They can send out
a beam of sound
from a fatty part of their
head called the melon.
The sound beam
bounces back and forms
a mental image in the dolphin's
brain of the world around them.
Echolocation is
the way that dolphins
have to see in dark and
low lit environments.
Basically, it's
like radar or sonar.
NARRATOR: But there are
limits to this super power.
So it works kind of like
wide beams on a flashlight.
They can only see
kind of directly ahead
of them or to the sides.
So if they get attacked from
the back or from underneath,
they probably won't see
the predator coming.
NARRATOR: Dolphins have a
blind spot, and sharks know it.
JASON DARKE: He's got
a dolphin in his mouth.
NARRATOR: Great whites
use their massive power
to charge from beneath
in a breach attack.
White sharks,
you would consider
more of an ambush predator.
It's probably
the shark that you
don't see that you worry about.
Because a lot of white
sharks rely on surprise.
They're stealth predators.
NARRATOR: It's easy to
sneak up on a lone dolphin.
But the safety of the
pod can stop an ambush,
even from a great white.
A white shark swims with
a group of dolphins.
The ocean going
mammals show no concern
for the killer in their midst.
Their ability to communicate
and spot their stalker
gives the shark no
chance at an attack.